olá boa tarde
devem estar a perguntar o porquê das
críticas aqui atrás
eles fazem parte de um exercício que
minha mãe fez quando era pequenininha
estava assim embaixo
por alguma razão que já não me recordo
muito bem ea oposto uma folha à frente
com rabiscos e forma tentar também que
eu ficasse melhor de si mas vamos tentar
fazer alguma coisa a partir daqui
tentei fazer um banho alguma coisa vamos
ver o que surge então eu comecei a ligar
estes trás
depois de alguma cor e depois de algum
tempo surgiu isto não foi exatamente
este que o vmware líquido pablo picasso
como eram que nem pior
contudo este é o melhor exemplo para
mostrar diz o meia que falar bem e falar
sobre criatividade submissão na cidade
que quer dizer passar de 16 anos nada ou
estar o lugar em nada e tornar algo
sublime parte ver como está disse que a
matéria seja passar do estado sol e
gostar de pessoas em que o estado só
estamos assim muito pesado estão a ser
muito muito chato muito preços não
conseguem ficar colado em um ipo no
estado caso estamos num estado de
verdade destas de energia cria com sorte
o stress da frase é também de queda nas
vendas e criatividade como a pobreza o
sentimento de desespero e um pouco de
pânico e nesta que ficarem da semci ice
na pobreza e no sentimento de desespero
ou sentimento de vazio ou mesmo a opção
informa que este último ponto está
associado à criatividade
nós temos aquelas figuras que ir ou
trans ou mesmo do outro temos causa eram
altamente criativas como por exemplo o
escritor ernest hemingway ou o pintor
van gogh ou mesmo no nosso caso em
portugal fernando pessoa e quer que eu
tinha em comum além de serem seja
altamente criativos e altamente possível
que eu também sei que pensavam em
demasia
entravam em grande prémio doutor
reflexão reflexão sobre o sobre o mundo
sobre o mais ínfimo pormenor como um
seja cor desta cadeira o contínuo teto
de vencer é muito difícil tentar impor
um pensamento profundo esquecimento
fundaç vezes trazem idéias menos
agradáveis trás depois podem conduzir a
dor ou sofrimento
acontece que é um é um processo é um
processo que eu não acho que o que as
pessoas fazem o que fazem com que o
sublime ou seja entram em períodos que
estão mais em baixo depois pega um pouco
divisão que tem neste sprint e conseguem
render mas não seremos todos nós capazes
de defeito ares não seremos todos nós
106 criativos sistani criatividade no
evento ao ser humano
não seremos todos nós capazes de jogar
neste momentos mais difíceis da nossa
vida e conseguir se firmar
temos tempo para essas partidas alguns
algumas peças
às vezes não seja daquela estão outras
vezes até mesmo conosco e não está em
baixo que não sabemos o que fazer
às vezes chegamos um pouco de diversão
que existe nessas alturas e aplicarmos
na criatividade
começamos a construir o que começamos a
juntar as peças por umas rodas dar um
pouco de design a idéia de quanto tempo
realmente ao construir
temos a nossa vida andar outra vez foi
um pouco isso que eu fiz numa altura em
que estava mais embaixo
foi um primeiro ano da faculdade e e
havia muita entrega muita reflexão sobre
o futuro sobre o presente é muita
matemática é muita física outras tantas
coisas com contribuíam para a confusão
em que estava e eu fiz um pouco aqui o
exercício cuco fernando pessoa fazia se
multiplicar
então eu transponho um pampa outras
áreas sejam deixar de estar aqui eu
estava
não deixe de fazer as coisas que fazia
no chão mesmo tempo transpus um para o
outro lado e comecei a escrever prosa
narrativa e pode até comprar uma
guitarra conseguir comprar as minhas
próprias coisas
e foi de facto uma forma de defender
naquela altura
hoje em dia se eu tentar escrever alguma
coisa tentar ganhar na guitarra não faz
tão bem como fazer naquela altura o que
é de certa forma curioso agora pegando
no outro ponto da frase continuamente a
pobreza forma que ela pode estar
associada à criatividade
nós estamos numa altura em que o
empreendedorismo em que o
empreendedorismo é de certa forma trend
ou seja 14 os criativos ou de
seguradores tartan antes mesmo da ufmt
estamos numa altura em que é muito fala
se muito de empreendedorismo dentro
desta linha eu fui pesquisar quais a que
os países mais empreendedores 2016
branco o seguinte o grande brasil
camarões de vento na angola jamaica
botsuana chega e filipinas e fiquei um
pouco surpreendido como é que o países
considerados desenvolvidos poderiam
estar no top dos países mais
empreendedores do mundo
nós somos as próprias raízes da
criatividade nos dizem fazer mais com um
pouco ultrapassar dificuldades
impulsionar pequenos negócios como a
escolha ver as coisas de outra forma e
evitar de dois programas seguintes o
primeiro imaginei que estão na
instituição
no filme namorada e toda a gente tem que
pôr comida na mesa mesmo o elemento mais
novo tem que ajudar a pôr comida na mesa
então começa a trabalhar em de novo
depois não se fixa passa outro e pouco
trabalho até certa altura ganha tanto
fita travagem que já tem que ver se tal
forma preenchido e veja quem não não
segue o percurso normal de escol a
faculdade a settra mas ganhar bagagem
estrofe e quando ainda jovem consegue
escalar impulsionar o negócio com tantas
idéias e com capacidade que já tem
o outro outro outro cenário é mais
criativo ao próprio cotidiano
neste país ou seja o que nós fomos como
cidade base que esses canais são um
obstáculo como por exemplo deixar o cão
d'água ou mesmo arranjar o gerador
porque faltou luz na comunidade ou
equacionar a comida por esta semana
tudo isto tarefas nós não temos
preocupar no nac nos países envolvidos
digamos são entramos numa flotilha de
conforto em que estas e esses problemas
associados às necessidades básicas dos
que nos passou pela cabeça e às vezes
como passou entramos em 3 quando na
realidade podemos pensar que o tenho que
pôr em prática a minha credibilidade
neste âmbito que já não punha algum
tempo e ele fez devolvidos
surge então o empreendedorismo em altura
já em alturas de não só gera desemprego
como também outras necessidades
financeiras e dentro do tempo
necessidade financeira e também cria
qualquer coisa eu cheguei mas queria
jogar por casa e e com estas técnicas de
fabricação que espera pedir quebra desde
pequenino e pequenos querem que a escola
tinha e comecei a pensar será que eu
posso fazer alguma coisa com isto
então surgiu a idéia de fazer 20 e mails
com críticas mas faltava material onde
agora vou arranjar tantas críticas
e foi com os bombeiros e eu ia passar
duas semanas conseguir um saco de cinco
quilos e cerveja transmitido do bairro
com baixo e todos os meses todos os
meses têm estes assim que o investimento
é mais difícil escoar do primeiro
conseguiu fazer nos produtos com 64
todas essas críticas mas também estava
fazendo um estágio etapa fazer tabelinha
placas de circuito impresso que são
aquelas com a questão dos computadores
anos também vamos também móveis e eu
estava a desenhar o que eu tinha que ser
funcional e funcional mas ao mesmo tempo
houve alguma arte além do do funcional
então eu comecei a olhar para o que
tinha lá por casa completamente montado
e móveis e também estava em uma outra
cidade e financeira e tentar fazer
alguma coisa
o primeiro pensaríamos promotoria por
aqui os jogadores cada 60 e 70 mas não
vamos pôr mais tipos mas foi mais tipo c
o fiz foi fazer uma simbiose entre
esferográfica e as placas eletrônicas de
surgiu esta idéia
outro micro negócio de anos
isso é um absurdo de anderson idéias
bastante simples não tiveram não tem
muito trabalho além do trabalho
artístico mas foram de fato de funções
que fizeram que eu sou e máximo na outra
cidade para mais que não seja uma altura
de conforto não sócrates fico com
conforto e econômica também que por
agora os dois pontos da frase de até 37
e tentar juntar aos e mostrar os
graficamente para no primeiro no
primeiro gráfico é gostava era um gift
um x prontos e acho que assim também dá
pra ficar no primeiro gráfico também
escalar mais ver um gráfico não ser
criativo altis baixos conseguiram esse
mal que embaixo alto baixo
vimos a nossa vida toda e assumirmos
serys também aussie baixo ao sim mas não
quero que olhem como se fossem gráfica
da criatividade na gráfica do humor o
pico é de felicidade e oval é uma opção
às necessidades financeiras com gráfico
nós achamos que a vida não é assim então
não tinha tem muitas arestas precisam
ser animadas e então não vai ser tão
bonitinho como do primeiro no terceiro
nós temos que fazer estas podem ser
melhores e dar ainda mais trabalho para
conseguirem ser animadas entrando sempre
diz de sanctis voltamos a china era
outra vez e assim continuamente ou então
um gráfico 4 em que os tempos não são
assim tão certo como os últimos gráficos
uma situação de humor e amor
pensamos muito mais tempo em alta
velocidade do propriamente em impressões
então eu tenho que ficar assegurado no
ponto 3
no quadrado que se imaginasse numa outra
cidade seja ela financeira sejam
ansiedade fugir ao sofrimento em questão
afetiva
seja o que for e pensei que nesta altura
então aqui em baixo podem errar os
pequenos pontos de diversão aplicar na
criatividade e sublimar na cidade
obrigado
[Aplausos]